um I'm actually probably the only
speaker today that's not going to have I
take a single equation so what I
actually want to tell you about today
are some of the things that we've been
developing in my lab motivated by all
the exciting developments in ancient DNA
to think about what the world could look
like if you had thousands and thousands
of ancient sampled sequence and as you
can imagine one of the huge limitations
to enabling such a world is that today
ancient DNA sequencing is
extraordinarily expensive so if you
sequence an ancient genome about 1% of
the reeds on average tend to be human
DNA 99% of them tend to be bacterial DNA
and so it's just extraordinarily
expensive you have to have a mox Blanc
or B sk bueller chev and have the sort
of backing of the Danish government in
order to be able to do a lot of this
kind of work and so in order to sort of
democratize ancient DNA sequencing we've
been working on techniques and methods
to try to make it more affordable that's
also been in part motivated by a lot of
the cool kind of evolutionary questions
we might be able to answer so I want to
tell you about the technology we
developed and then some extensions of it
to two problems one is orthogonal
validation so one of the big problems I
think we have an ancient DNA is that few
samples have actually been sequenced
more than once on two different
technologies and so we don't really have
often a good understanding of what our
true errors need in the data versus real
differences except for some of the high
coverage and so if it's expensive to
sequence a low coverage genome you can
book you can understand it's
extraordinarily expensive to sequence a
high coverage sample and then one
actually cool thing that's come out of
this is that you can think about the
inverse problem which is that imagine a
sample where you have human as the
contaminant and you want to sequence the
bacteria and this is something like
human blood and we've actually just
gotten some very preliminary results
that say we may be able to do that so I
wanted to share those and think about
some of the analytical challenge that
come down the pike in thinking about
sort of Maj and omics where the
meta-genome examples are actually it
sort of low abundance okay so I don't
need to tell you about why a t-dna
is exciting or the problems that are
involved I do want to start with this
story so we got involved because of this
character this guy named see the Iceman
let's see was found about 20 years ago
now on the border between Austria and
Italy and he's one of the most
extraordinarily well-preserved ancient
samples so they found an entire sort of
frozen mummy so you know this is about
ideal conditions he's been kept on ice
for five thousand years and they several
years ago started a collaboration
because when they found his genome it
turned out when they found it would say
it turned out he'd not only sort of died
in this crevasse he actually had been
murdered and so I think the only way to
solve a good murder is to sequence the
genome and so in a collaboration with
ABI they sequenced it and even in this
extraordinarily well-preserved case
where you have a sort of bone biopsy
it's about forty percent human DNA and
they did about an 8x genome and we were
involved in the analysis for those of
you who are interested you can read the
paper here and one of the very cool
results that came out of that analysis
and what we were involved with some of
you know we've been working on powder to
the European diversity now for several
years this is from a paper we had with
John novembre and when we pc8 up [ __ ]
you know so you would have expected him
to sort of pca out of here so here's
sort of our map of europe here's the
iberian peninsula your Switzerland
here's where you'd expect him to pca oh
but it turned out that good old Otzi pca
it up with these sort of five italian
samples that we'd always sort of swept
under the rug and so we sort of went
back yeah you know what's up with those
five italians it turned out they weren't
just any random five Italians they were
Sardinians and when we looked closer at
the data it turned out that Otzi carried
a mutation on his Y chromosome that had
never been described before and Peter
Underhill who's now a research associate
in the lab and of course the many he
knows
worked for many years on the Y
chromosome genotype that sample rgo
typed that marker in a huge collection
of samples that he had and one
extraordinarily interesting result that
came out of this is that the present-day
relatives at least the male relatives of
Otzi are all on the island of Corsica
and Sardinia okay so here's this 5,000
year old dead guy and we can tell you
with sort of pinpoint accuracy at least
about his male relatives it's only
became very interested in this problem
and you can imagine right you know the
sort of two scenarios one scenario is
that Lexi really was sardinian and you
know if you're sardinian and you want to
go on vacation you go to the Alps and
maybe that's what he was killed you know
who's this Sardinian guy here you know
and that's why he got ice as it were or
perhaps Europe 5,000 years ago look very
different than it does today and really
the only way to answer that is with lots
of ancient samples from lots of
different time points and that's sort of
where we decided to sort of take this
okay so now on to the technology and
this is really a project that's been led
by Meredith carpenter who is a really
extraordinary postdoc in the lab
Meredith was actually a PhD student here
at Berkeley and Jason buenrostro who's a
PhD student at Stanford in will
Greenleaf lab and what we want to
develop was a very inexpensive whole
genome capture technique that would
allow us to take that soup of molecules
that have both human DNA and the
bacterial DNA and whatever other things
are in the soup and sort of pull out the
human molecules and we want to apply it
to a real-world set of samples and so we
got our hands on these for Iron Age and
Bronze Age human teeth from Bulgaria
seven different Peruvian mummies that we
analyzed in collaboration with with SK
slab as well as a Bronze Age hair sample
from Denmark and then we wanted to
intersect it way in the sort of thousand
g don't data ask well how well can we do
with these sorts of data just taking I
mean we didn't certainly for the
garyun samples we didn't know what we
were going to get we didn't know the
quality of these who these are sort of
representative what you might expect to
get from samples that may be sitting
around in people's museums ok so the
outline of the talk i'll describe whisk
in a bit of cursory detail for those
Granderson has been published in the
paper last year in the American Journal
of Human Genetics well then tell you
about the orthogonal validation work and
then close with the work on metagenomics
and I also want to acknowledge Martin
Sakura who's a postdoc who's done much
of the analysis that I'll be talking
about particularly for the second part
okay so here is how whisk works and the
the details are really quite
straightforward so you can imagine that
one one big problem what you want to do
capture is the last thing you want to do
is introduce human DNA into an ancient
DNA library right so you're not going to
want to bait with human DNA so one thing
you could do is bait with RNA and so the
big problem then becomes what is your
source of RNA and the real insight that
Meredith had was well what if we were
just to transcribe the entire human
genome so imagine taking human DNA
adding bacterial promoters and just
making boatloads and boatloads and
boatloads of RNA and that's basically
what we do so we can then ask how well
does the method work but just think
about it in that way so you then go
through and you add these probes to the
RNA that you're going to use in your
capture to pull them down okay so the
other part works in exactly the same way
that ancient DNA normally works so you
take your ancient tooth your do your DNA
extraction in our case the red bits here
are the human DNA the black bits here or
the environmental DNA you made your
sequencing library in the traditional
way and then you capture the library and
this is all in the in the paper this is
the way you would normally capture and
then you pull them out with with the way
you normally do capture using these
struct out of em beads okay that's all
the molecular biology we're gonna do
today so you can imagine that there
a ton of stuff under the hood here and
as anyone who knows me knows that I had
nothing to do with the lab lab what lab
work it was all Meredith and so I'm
happy to answer questions around asleep
pass them on to Meredith and then passed
on to you the answers but now I want to
tell you about the results so here are
the samples so we had four iron bronze
age teeth and these sort of straddled
from about fifteen hundred to five
hundred DC we had a one nice hair sample
and that's this guy here and then we had
this mummy that perhaps looked like some
of you felt maybe this morning if you
went out drinking late last night or
maybe how you felt when I told you I
didn't have any equations in the slides
today okay and so here are some of the
data and what I'm showing you is the
number of reads that math pre and post
caption so in blue here is pre capture
and in red it looks like post capture
and you can imagine this this almost
looks like an advertisement from the
back of a magazine that you order
reagents for right the red does much
better than the blue right and so one
thing you might ask you well you know
how well are we doing and are we biasing
it and you really see I mean this is one
of the most egregious examples of how
well you do you're kind of going from
about one to two percent of the reads
mapping to the human genome upwards to
about sixty percent of the reads mapping
of the human genome but of course we may
only be getting a very small fraction of
the human genome right so if the method
is not working well then there's not
much to to be excited about so one of
the things that we were concerned about
is coverage right so if one thing you
could do is say map these to the human
genome here are two examples so here is
one library pre capture and these are
all the sort of reeds and where they're
lining up to and here it is post capture
and when you're supposed to take away
from this is that basically every place
we're getting reached pre capture we're
getting them post capture so I make
sense and the likewise for another
library pre and post captured okay and
imagine there better ways of quantifying
this in terms of overlap and so on the
other thing that became and this is sort
of just for one of the libraries for
this is one
the native american libraries that we
ran twice so this is for about 12
million reads that were sequenced this
is the post capture right about two
hundred thousand reads post capture
50,000 of them are common to the pre
capture and there were about sixteen
thousand reads and the pre capture that
we didn't see the post capture and you
might imagine that if we sequenced more
of the post capture we might get back
some of these reads that make sense okay
so here is some of the kind of methods
II bit that we became interested in
because one of the big questions is how
to think about the problem in terms of
efficiency and Simone Gravelle who is a
postdoc in the lab has has helped us
think about this in part it's similar a
map to recapture problem so you can
imagine that there's a trade-off in how
much you invest in sequencing a given
library versus what you're going to get
out of it because the more you sequence
the library the more you're going to
begin to sample the same molecule right
you begin to get so called duplicates
and so what I'm plotting here is the
number of unique fragments that you're
getting and you have this so-called
right I mean not the law of diminishing
returns that as you sequence you're
beginning to get duplicates okay so what
you love and what we're basically
getting with this technology is that
with the post capture so red is post
capture blue is pre captured right with
the post capture we're basically already
shooting ourselves into that world where
many of the molecules are duplicates
normally if you have a lot of duplicates
in your library that's viewed as a bad
thing right that means you have low
complexity but really what's happening
here is that there aren't that many
unique molecules to sample in the first
place and so here's you know what you
would get with the free capture if you
were to be sequencing it out and out now
now you're kind of going to meet this
same curve and so the capture kind of
allows you to get back
and then our enrichment is really the
ratio of those two curves obviously
right the mortgage sequence the you know
the less meaningful the capture is right
the more you sequence the less there's
going to be an enrichment relative to
the two and this is giving you a sense
for the two so this is the the Danish
hair sample you know more enrichment
here because they're sort of more
duplicates this is a more sort of
complex library and so there's sort of
some less in Richmond but in general
right you're still benefiting from doing
the caption does that make sense
everyone on board okay so and for those
of you are interested Simone has also
been thinking a lot about this issue of
capture recapture as it relates not only
two molecules and sequencing of the DNA
libraries but also to identifying
variant I encourage you to talk to him
okay so because of this issue of the
duplicate reads the number of fragments
that are mapping to the human genome is
really not a fair statistic to report as
to how well the method works right
because really if it's a kind of shitty
library right then you know you're just
going to be sequencing duplicates and
not getting a lot of extra information
so one way that we thought about
quantifying the amount of information
that you're getting is as a function of
a fixed number of sequencing reads so
this is something like per million reads
that you sequence how many snips are you
finding pre and post capture okay so
here are the different libraries and the
numbers here these are all that sort of
native american libraries p 192 is one
library that's particularly interesting
i'll go back to this this is the one
that we've now also sequenced on ion
torrent this is one of the bulgarian
libraries and so you see that you know
even in this guy this is a this is a
pretty good library you know we're
getting a two-fold enrichment and doing
the capture so it's still quite
beneficial to do the capture whereas for
others right this one you sequence a
million reads you're only getting 600
snips but if you do the capture you get
4,000 steps right so you know there's
there's quite a nice increase in the
number of snips that you're betting and
we're basically getting
usable data from every one of the
samples that we tried so this is
actually for us quite encouraging
because it means that in some sense
almost any ancient DNA sample is going
to be amenable to some degree of
analysis based on this kind of a capture
technology as long as you know you have
proper checks in there that you're doing
a good job in terms of the uniformity of
the sampling which is really one of the
motivations for why we then decided to
look at this orthogonal technology
question okay so now on to what can you
hope to learn and does it really
actually help us in any semblance of
population genetic analysis and so you
know one of the things you might imagine
wanting to do is is just a straight-up
PCA intersecting the snips with you know
sort of existing a databases so this is
sort of a kind of collection of data you
might use in this case it's sort of
thousand genomes snips this is the set
of Asian diversity space here the set of
African samples you're the set of
European samples and you know the
shockingly revolutionary conclusion here
is that you know the Bulgarian ancient
DNA sample clusters with the Europeans
which you know you know we've got nature
and science or two vying for that result
right now well you know who goes for it
what's cool though is if you do do the
capture you are able to you know begin
to get into a world where you do begin
to get some very nice potential
sub-continental ancestry and I'll dig
into this topic a bit further
particularly talking about some of
Martin's results you know in this
particular case the post capture is
giving us about tenfold more snips and
so you know now you're really talking
and beginning to ask questions about
well can we distinguish different you
know source populations is it possible
to say who is more closely related to
whom and if you really sort of had
blanketed and had good set of samples it
may be possible okay another example
this is our horrified Peruvian mummy
who's just concerned about both the
molecular biology that's being discussed
and the statistics and just one
nothing to do with the top at all
perhaps they were also concerned that
when we PC aid them up they pc8 up with
with asians and not necessarily you know
with Native Americans and and this is a
concern for the mummy because they this
money actually has blond hair and there
was a sort of question about whether
this money could be Native American or
in fact could have some degree of
European ancestry it's actually a
pre-columbian mummy however when you go
to the post capture you see that in fact
it is pc eng up right where you expect
of a nice sort of native american sample
and so we're very excited to be
following this up in some more detail
okay so to sort of summarize the sort of
results for where we are or were you
know how the method is working you know
for the positive pasture on average you
start with about 1.2 percent human DNA
post capture we've got enough to about
sixty percent human DNA and we're
working on improving this enrichment of
molecules between 52 140 x enrichment of
snips from about 2 to 20 x and you're
getting somewhere on the order of about
fifty thousand snips per million samples
okay so we really are quite excited
about this and are not trying this on
dozens and dozens of samples and
exporting it to other labs yeah David so
once joy have is the this is very
interesting this I think is very excited
potentially so so one thing you would
like to do is get to get whole genome
level of
large proportion of the genome yeah what
is the largest amount of data for the
single sample that comes through this
process so I'll show you well I mean it
all depends on the endogenous DNA
content so everything plated I guess
what is the largest I'll show you the
data that we have on one library that we
sequenced on ion torrent which is the
most complex that we have that's coming
up in fact thank you for the sort of
leading so one of the things that we
were very interested in is this is sort
of this question of orthogonal
validation and trying to see how well
the data that are coming in and out are
so we've sequenced this sample in
collaboration with ion as well as on the
high seek as well and that's supposed to
be whisk as well as using our whisk
technology and this is sort of a plug
for where this began this is part of
this project that Martin is leading
where he has taken the set of published
genomes as well as our Bulgarian sample
where and this we've now sort of
increase this in the data that I'm about
to show you and I'll motivate it by
saying if you take and this is sort of
the kind of going back to this question
about we're sort of sardinia fits in
relative to the rest of europe so Martin
took these hunter-gatherer samples so
there's a Swedish hunter-gatherer data
set that had had come out from pontus
and Swedish group and they had a
hunter-gatherer and a farmer there's the
Iberian hunter-gatherer we put an Iceman
and the Bulgarians and so one of the
main results of that analysis and so if
you use davids detest and you look at
Iceman for example so the detest is
you'll recall is a test for gene flow
where you'd have for example here's
Sardinia here is our ancient sample
here's what we're comparing to and so if
you have in this particular case Iceman
this is sort of the z-score and it's
telling you what is the D statistic and
then this is sort of the level of the
z-score there's strong evidence for more
affinity between the Sardinia and the
ancient genome than any one of these so
so evidence for in particular the Finns
cluster particularly out and there's a
reason for that separately but so the
take-home is that the Iceman is closer
to Sardinians than to print CEU Iberian
tour Tuskens and you can say that quite
confidently that make sense and that's
because of the strength of the not so
much because the strength of the effect
but because of the strength of the data
right there's a tremendous amount of
data because this Iceman was sequence to
high coverage so when you look at the
other samples which is sort of this
motivation to taking it to higher
coverage so the Swedish farmer shows the
same pattern as ice man so close sir the
the more clustering with the Sardinians
of the farmers be they the Swedish
farmers be an Iceman or our Bulgarian
then the hunter-gatherers and the
hunter-gatherers trend towards where the
samples were taken so both the Swedish
and the Iberian hunter-gatherers are
sort of closer to the Finns Brits and
see you okay and there's lots of folks
are thinking about this problem and the
impact this has on models of for the
people of Europe and if we've got time
again I'll show you Martin's thoughts on
that but I just want to sort of focus in
on this issue which is this is all being
driven of course not so much by the
effect size but the fact that the amount
of data that you have you know these
confidence intervals are traveling
straddling 0 so if you could you know
increase the amount of data you do a
much better job than being able to
estimate the actual value of those d
statistics ok so here's the data or at
least you know let's begin to talk about
the data so we sequenced that Bulgarian
ancient DNA library in this case this is
what the aluminum free capture was it
sort about 313 million reads from those
13 million reads you
all about 43,000 snips and you have
about 11 mega bases of the human genome
that this is mapping to okay so
definitively not a high coverage genome
right our post capture data in fact is
even less it's less than the we had in
the pre capture you know that's why we
call some few tips in the post capture
it's it's actually less overlap by the
proton data was you know sort of through
the roof and here we've got about a 467
mega bases of sequence and again this is
beginning to tap out we've got you know
this is it I don't remember the exact
numbers but it's in love the 28 to some
percent duplicates and we call about
400,000 snips okay so now to get to this
point David which i think is an
important one here is perhaps a worrying
slide but I want us to think about this
because I think it's an important slide
ok here is the intersection of the data
so here's where all of the proton data
is mapping here is the alumina pre
capture here's the aluminum post capture
okay so now let's think about what may
be happening in this experiment so we
have two DNA extracts well x sorry we
have the same DNA extracted made
libraries twice one for the pre capture
and 11 for the alumina libraries and one
for the proton libraries now when you
sequence the proton library right you
don't yet have a 30x genome right so
this is seek this is mapping 2.1 x to
the genome right and these guys are
mapping to some other part of the genome
muckle I mean we have good overlap
between the pre and post capture the
reason the post capture doesn't cover
everything in the pre captures because
we have in sequence tit to higher
coverage we could sequence the higher
come does that make sense the other
possibility and there's another
possibility is that in both the library
construction or in the captor you're
losing so many molecules that you know
the whole thing is is you know a concern
for reproducibility yeah
I don't but I have some other results
that sort of speak to this issue i think
it's all it's largely driven by the
coverage issue if you can let me to get
yeah we got it is usable but is it quite
serious loss of complexity so it's great
I agree so but we need a more library
sequence to higher coverage in order to
address that issue so I'll take it a one
place statistics I'll take it one place
where we actually do have high coverage
where we might be able to address on the
news about this so you can take the
curves right and those curves could you
could get you know what is the expected
over a lot given the degree of coverage
but I'll take you to one just let me get
to this point which is that we do have
some parts of the genome that are
sequence to quite high coverage namely
the my toe right because the there are
many many more copies of the my toe in
the data then there are the nuclear
genome right so you've got two molecules
of the nuclear genome in every cell but
you've got many many more copies of the
mitochondrial DNA so if you look at the
mitochondrial coverage in the alumina
free capture we've got something like
whether we can sort of them read it off
on their looks about 12 2x and we've got
about 2 to 3 x coverage in the post
capture and we've got 20 to 30 x
coverage in the in the proton data so
from the proton data we actually have
quite good coverage and can make quite
good reliable calls on the my toe and
then ask relative to the alumina how
well are we doing and this is under the
data that's and this is sort of
literally just coming in and I want to
thank Martin and and Meredith and I
actually view this as quiet you know
potentially positive right namely that
if you look at where we're able to map
pre and post capture and with the proton
data we're getting quite decent coverage
in all three datasets in terms of the
actual coverage of the my toe from the
whole genome capture right and the whole
genome capture also has the my toe as
part of the capture right because you're
just making it from whole g
whole human genome DNA that make sense
yeah now just because we've got somewhat
higher coverage of this and this is
actually an important point the data is
still sort of 12 2x data and remember
that the alumina technology still has
one to two percent error so the actual
quality of the data is not spectacular
oh so here's some of the my toe coverage
data here and I'll show you several
plots like this this is post capture
recapture and I on right and you can see
what the difference is you know pre and
post capture right and you're not losing
you know in terms of the number of
molecules we had in the pre capture and
the post capture library we're basically
getting everything we had at least in
our hand and part of it is you know
we're not targeting specific snips right
we're targeting whatever molecules are
in the SU that are binding to the human
genome all right now what did the you
know it could also be able got a ton of
contamination in the data right so you
know maybe we're just you know
sequencing Meredith or something like
that turns out that's not the case the
substitution types are exactly what you
would expect from ancient DNA largely C
2 T&G to a substitutions they also
follow the kind of characteristic
patterns is actually so here's a kind of
cool result you know so you've probably
all seen these sorts of results where
the error rates go up towards the end of
the molecule but one cool bag is that
there is somewhat of a difference
between the proton and the alumina
patterns and this is perhaps
attributable to the way that these two
libraries are made due to the 80
overhang at this at the second position
okay so for those of you who kind of
want to geek out on that I'll leave you
to think about that okay now here is
actually some of the things we're now
burrowing into so if you now think about
the pre and post caps or library and
what you've run this is for the minoan
per ticket
because it's still low coverage genome
sequencing there's not a spectacular
concordance so there's about twenty four
variants that get called 12 of those get
called as non-reference in both and then
each data set calls six variants that
the other data set doesn't pre and post
capture at least running it through gatk
okay and this is due to the fact that
you often have you know one maybe two
reads that are going to support a
variant okay and this is not surprised
pokes because we have one percent error
right this is going to happen right to
yep you can we've been experimenting
with me calibrating yep particularly
using the mitochondria yes so when you
say gatk it may be the best Kevin
proposed the saying that will save you a
little little I'm sure there are I'm
sure there are and i'll show you some
additional results there that kind of
speak to this yeah the mitochondria
there are a lot of chimeric inserts in
the all of them right so when you go to
call variants it seems like you could
have an issue with Vince mapping it
actually came from milks weird
potentially also an issue hi those are
all very good question I'm sort of just
giving you where we are with this okay I
think it's actually in the sequencing
and in fact there is actually probably
JDK and I'll show you this the this sort
of result which is that we do have the
proton data so they're in the proton
data there were six sites that had
coverage on the aluminum okay and those
six sites got called with hiking court
you know got called reliably on the post
capture for sites got called on a free
capture and two sites were failed to be
called by gatk and the pre capture I'll
show you the data for those two sides
but the upshot is that in fact the reeds
were going in the right direction so in
fact the evidence is there it's an issue
of sort of calibrating and getting it to
work perhaps the more worrying issue is
there are about 20 sites that got called
in the alumina data
I on did not call and we don't know if
that's currently I on bro you know and
then you know i'm showing you the data
warts and all this is literally data
that we've been working on up until
today that i was excited about and want
to tell you so these could be I on under
calls or they could be alumina errors
you know I on because they've had issues
before tend to be very very aggressive
in their poly ok but the point is the
only way that we can begin to ground
truth this data is by beginning to get
orthogonal validation and there are
almost no data sets that I know of where
you have orthogonal validation for
ancient DNA samples that's why we're
trying to do this okay so here are two
examples where the breeds so here's the
ion data here's the pre capture data and
a dozen get called by gatk here's the
post capture data that does call it and
it turns out the only difference between
these two is the quality score that gets
assigned by gatk in this pre capture
instance right so this is a false
negative it should have gotten called
but it just you know didn't get called
in this particular instance and the
other one is the same scenario okay one
thing you can do after you sort of begin
to deal with all these issues is make
calls and one thing that's very cool
about this particular sample it turns
out to be a you three be mitochondria
and what's exciting about that
distribution first of all you know if
you sort of look it up on 23andme first
population examples Bulgarian so that's
good that's where the sample comes from
and it's also sort of you know the sort
of middle eastern population center of
diversity and so you know one sort of
model could be that this 3,000 year old
Bulgarian sample is part of that sort of
initial Neolithic expansion into Europe
and there are a lot of these use that
you actually tend to see in an ancient
DNA we can also call the Y chromosome
and in this particular case what's cool
is that this is a Capital Group E Y
chromosome and as you know this is kind
of a classic
group from the Bantu expansion but you
also see it in North Africa and some
southern European populations and so you
know the sample assignments of the my
toe in the Y makes sense and we're
excited and beginning to take this to
higher coverage and again sort of the
the the bigger picture idea is that you
know this it's the beginning to open up
more and more samples that could be
amenable to this kind of dissection now
on to some pca and I'd like to call this
perhaps the worst pca we've ever
produced in the lab know sort of offense
is the precap for pca for the bulgarian
sample of course it you know looks like
a row sharp blob you can read whatever
you want i mean in general pca zorro
sharp lots but this is at least a row
sharp blot with more resolution in which
you know this is our sort of map of
europe pca which at least from the
proton data we're beginning to see that
our Bulgarian sample is you know by the
incredibly sophisticated method of
drawing the circle is a pc eng of near
are four or five certain examples so
that's where we are on that orthogonal
validation project we're quite excited
about it and beginning to think about
additional sources of sequencing that we
can bring to bear to ground through some
of these samples and again if there are
high coverage samples that we could try
our capture on we've we'd be happy to
try them out and begin to build a sort
of reference set out there that could be
used okay her my on time Andy I have
three minutes okay I'm going to just
turn to the last bit which won't take
very long so you can imagine that in the
same way that we can do positive capture
instead of sequencing what you captured
you could do some clever things and
sequence what you didn't capture so keep
the UM
DNA and you might ask well why on earth
would you want to do that and there are
certain scenarios particularly in
metagenomic applications where there's a
lot of interest in low-level bacteria or
viruses that may be circulating I was
just a gbt last week and Joe Theresa
gave just an amazingly beautiful talk
about a kid that was seen at UCSF that
had severe combined immunodeficiency
syndrome and the kid had been sick with
an infection for a year and was just
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse they finally sequenced a spinal
tap turned out the kid had a form of
meningitis that you know nobody that you
know that with all the other assays they
weren't able to get it and they they did
it by sequencing you know from the I
don't know how many many tens of
millions of reeds only 400 were to the
spirochetes you could imagine if there
was some way to reduce the human you
might be able to detect it with far
fewer reads okay so we've done some mock
experiments in this regard this is work
not Makos arm of the real experiments
but they're sort of samples that were
set up one is a saliva sample and these
were kind of designed for sort of am I
seek so about 10 million reads in the
initial library about fifty percent of
the reeds map to the human genome fifty
percent a sort of microbial we do our
depletion and this is to be honest the
best example we have in this particular
case we go from about fifty percent
human to about three percent human and
you know one way of quantifying this
might be as an odds ratio and knowledge
race is about 31 so you
yeah you capture the human you use whisk
and then you sequence the other bit and
here's some additional samples so here's
a cheek swab and then here are two human
soil samples these are after does anyone
know what human soils these are these
are the ones from the British these
aren't the picture is of the footprints
in Britain that came out for me these
aren't the ones we sequenced those would
be very cool to see points but you know
we didn't get our hands on that yeah
that would be great if you know what
virus you were looking for in our case
we don't know what virus we're looking
for right and that's one of the main
applications and metagenomics so of
course one potential problem with this
right that immediately comes up is you
could very well lose the cool viruses
you're looking for in your caption right
that's one of the potential difference
oh so here are the again the depletions
from 40 to twenty percent 2718 percent a
year you know again it very frustrated
all sort of very much work in progress
you know it's a knowledge ratio of 31
these are sort of more g was--like odds
ratios about two to three but you know
odds races of two to three or sometimes
also very important and we're in the
process of trying to get those two to
we're sequencing under the beaks as it
were trying to get them to improve and
again you know again very first kind of
preliminary results on this one thing
that's a very kind of logical thing to
try to do is ask well with the frequency
of the bugs pre and post capture and you
know for lack of a better reason just to
sort of spread out so we could look at
this in fig arranged i plotted here the
sort of square root of the frequency
pleat pre depletion and post depletion
so first the buds makes sense for what
you'd find in somebody saliva bunch of
streptococcus samples and you know so
what's happening in this particular case
these are things that you know we had
some frequency of pre depletion and then
post depletion we kind of lost so you
know in this particular experiment we
did lose some but there were others that
you know did pretty well and the
correlation here is about you know
ninety-two percent which is you know for
a first-time stab at it not a bad
correlation were you know continuing to
follow this through here's a second
example this is one that was a sort of
cheek swab this one's doing somewhat
better and in this particular case this
is actually a bacteria that causes
gingivitis I'm sure they're much cheaper
ways of potentially diagnosing somebody
with gingivitis but
way this is what we got so we're excited
about this we're following it up and
particular trying to get real samples
where you have you know low amounts of
the bacterial DNA that you'd like to
sequence and so you could imagine
transplant patients and other scenarios
where this kind of sequencing might be
useful so that just like to close and
say that you know we're still very much
in the early days of getting this
working we've developed this gold
standard set of samples or we're
thinking about trying to get these gold
stamper and it would be good to sort of
get a community to kind of rally around
a set of samples that get sequence using
multiple technologies so we begin to
really ground truth these and in the way
that say genome in a bottle is doing
this for some of the hapmap samples and
some of the PGP samples the depletion
results so far look encouraging we're
working on reproducing them we've had
other experiments that so far haven't
been as exciting but we're working on it
it's coming down the pike and the other
cool thing is that you can do whisk for
anything for which you have a a DNA
library so you actually don't need a
genome so one project we have is a sort
of dodo genome sequencing project where
we're making the DNA Bates from nikka
bar pigeon and you know we'll then build
a nick of our genome but you don't need
a nick of our genome and you know sort
of a good nickel bar assembly but rather
just a source of the nick of our DNA in
order to be so with that I want to thank
the folks have been involved
particularly Meredith and Martin this is
really a lot of their work will my
colleague at Stanford we've done a lot
of this work with and for any questions
I encourage you to ask Meredith and
Martin than happy to pass them along
thank
yeah seems like the depletion worked a
lot better personalize their cheek swab
and perfume soil is unjust graph to give
it into what that's n equals 1 so I
wouldn't you know we don't know we'll
try it again I wouldn't make a lot of it
yeah just yet so the DNA content very
similar at least in terms of proportion
you know their other thinking other
other approaches out there so like any
be has a kid that pulls up methylated
DNA or kind of destroys methylated DNA
and bacteria don't have methylated DNA
but this is what will come yeah
yeah yeah I mean normally you do this
like 69 sequencing if you're what you
care about psyd you would normally do
the 16s sequencing and not in this case
I think the reason to do this instead of
16s sequencing is that this would allow
you to also get out whether the you
might get lucky if the pathogen had some
kind of pathogenicity island or
something you would you could
potentially find it here by sequencing
to high coverage and building the genome
that you couldn't necessarily do from
doing the 16s sequencing if that makes
sense right because the 16s is only
going to kind of tag it all comes down
to the initial library complexity yeah
yeah for sure you're interested in a
micro bio micro biomes typically have
you know a few abundant bugs in this
long time yeah extremely rare things
anything that you do that restricts
complexity you don't lose that yeah so
if you're interested in rare stuff yeah
yeah so the other thing you could do is
you could do the capture so we had made
with so you can do the few could also do
the capture pre library right you can
capture before you do the library
construction right issue complexity
original sample that's also right but no
so in our case the reason we do the
capture pose is because the libraries
are made in ancient DNA lab so for the
metagenomics no there must be a pcr
amplified it before you write
alright let's take a coffee break and be
back here promptly at eleven